in this episode of Battle Damage Koosh
suitor requested that we bid a fond
farewell to this iPhone 5s and then we
can all get the new iPhone 6
yay consumerism
this super popular smartphone hang on
one sec I just got a text back what five
emails one sec there are three basic
tests here on battle damage drop from a
normal height drop from really high and
finally a test of extreme limits and
it'll all be captured with our
hand-built 360 degree slo-mo camera rig
these screens are pretty tough I don't
think it's going to shatter on the first
test but we'll see action there is a
little damage where it's right here it's
the tiniest little piece no one would
notice this
speed action slowly fine screen is
untouched how's that chip has it
enlarged or is it the same it's got a
matching one on the caddy corner okay
but that's it with Apple's recent
security issues we thought it'd be best
to test the iPhone with something safe
okay so this is the heaviest and most
unwieldy object we've ever dropped we
have done a cinder block you've done it
Hannibal this safe is about 55 pounds
and big roll action
Oh
oh that was awesome guy nailed it
there's like iPhone dust everywhere oh
well there's the battery it's a with EMI
oh honey there's a SIM card okay but one
other interesting thing look what the
iPhone did to the safe this is from this
that's how strong it is Siri what should
we battle test next I am in so much pain
please kill me